hey guys it is Friday which means I'm
here with my friends down an edge to
tell you what's been going on in gaming
also it's some Patrick's Day so I bought
in this green pillow to celebrate are
you guys excited first up sony has
revealed the first of april's free
playstation plus games god of war and
twisted metal creator david jaffe is
releasing drawn to death on april four
it's set to be 20 bucks but PlayStation
Plus subscribers will be able to pick it
up for free the brand new game is a
multiplayer arena style brawler with a
distinct sketchbook art style as the
name implies Sony haven't shared the
rest of April's PlayStation Plus line up
just yet but you can grab marches
freebies which include discs gem and
tearaway unfolded right now Microsoft
massively teased Xbox fans this week by
putting up a project Scorpio product
page the products page for the console
which promises to be the most powerful
system ever made doesn't feature a
release date or a price but there are a
couple of notable tidbits the page lists
the project Scorpio is the first and
only console to enable true 4k gaming
and high fidelity VR is compatible with
all xbox one games and accessories and
includes six teraflops of graphical
processing power holy mackerel you can
also provide your email to be notified
of more projects Scorpio details Xbox
boss Phil Spencer said we may hear more
about the console before e3 and also
during the show itself grand theft auto
online latest update arrived this week
and it's called cunning stunts a special
vehicle circuit a title I'm being very
careful to pronounce correctly the
update adds 20 new stunt racers
specifically designed to take advantage
of the unique qualities of the rocket
Baltic ruiner 2000 and blazer aqua cars
the courses take place everywhere from
the sky to the water so if you're
looking for more variety in your racing
this should sort you out all the new
races are currently paying out double
GTA bucks and RP 32 Wednesday March 22nd
this weeks update also introduces the
draw were the approach and gp1 and there
are a whole bunch of discounts on
in-game items for all the specifics head
to our story on gamespot
I know what the people want down lying
down and updates on battlefield won the
day shall not pass update is available
now for those who own the fifty-dollar
premium pass while everybody else will
be able to pick it up on March 28 the
expansion adds the French army and four
new maps set in sacrebleu France that's
all the French I know oh wait I know
cafe means coffee and petite means
little mm-hmm it also introduces two new
operations six unlockable weapons for
melee weapons a new behemoth tank and
the trench Raider elite class a new mode
called front lines is also arriving with
the expansion if you'd rather not part
with your hard earned dollar reduce
you'll still get stuff like spectator
mode balance changes and bug fixes to
make battlefield one even more realistic
so now it doesn't rain inside on the
giant shadow map and it's all free free
check out our story on site for the full
very not petite patch notes into that
horror game where a guy cuts off
people's penises is getting a sequel out
last two and it's been infused
classification in Australia which means
it can't be sold here and is effectively
banned so Australia's always had a long
history of banning video games since we
didn't always have an adult rating that
restricted games to anyone under the age
of 18 stuff like GTA san andreas and
fallout three were initially refused
classification and had to be edited to
get released but even though we've had
an r18 waiting for some time now some
[ __ ] is just too extreme for what
Australia's classification board deems
acceptable and in the case of outlast to
its implied sexual violence the board
report obtained by Kotaku described some
of the offending scenes and yeah it's
all intense check out our story if you
want more details so unless developer
red barrels decides to edit those
moments to fall within what the board
deems acceptable outlast who will
legally be unavailable for sale in
Australia I reached out to them and
asked him what they were going to do but
they haven't gotten back to me so if
anyone sees them tell them to return my
calls please this week on site we chat
breath of the wild Easter eggs and give
you a look at Mass Effect Andromeda
small t player gameplay and now in the
spirits about last two here's a montage
of every single game Australia has
refused classification do
[Music]
[Music]
that's it from me this week the boys
have already gone to play video games
and I should probably get on that too so
I will see you again on Monday have a
great weekend